مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبدا وهكذا المعتاد بالعلوي
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن السيطره على مدينه
سيلداري وكيف تنفي وتصف المعارك في
المدينه
على افراد وكيانه ايرانيه وادراج الحرس
الثوري على قوائم الارهاب
الجمارك والسعوديه تحبط محاوله تهريب اكثر
من 80 كلغ من الحشيش عبر منفذ الوديعه
الرابعه
المسرح المدرسي في اكثر من تسعه عشره الف
مدرسه في السعوديه
والارصاد السعوديه تحذر منه طول امطار
غزيره على عده مناطق في جنوب وغربي وسط
البلد
البدايه من مستجدات القتال في سوريا دار
حيث نفى الجيش الاوكراني فقدان السيطره
على المدينه
العنيفه مستمر وقبل ذلك اعلنت الدفاع
الروسيه سيطره الكامله على مدينه
ستسمح بقطع الامدادات عن القوات
الاوكرانيه في بخموث وانها خطوه حاسمه في
العمليات الهجوميه في اوكرانيا
نحو مدينه التي تتمركز فيها قوه اوكرانيه
واقعه بين ليست تشانس في لوجان
سيطره على المحور الشمالي باكم في المرحله
المقبله
في مساء الثانيه عشر من يناير تم تحرير
مدينه سوليدار وهو امر مهم لاستمرار
العمليات الهجوميه الناجحه في اتجاه
دوناتسك ان فرض السيطره كامله على سوليدار
يجعلو من الممكن قطع طرق الامداد للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مدينه باخموت الواقعه الى
الجنوب الغربي السيطره على سوريا
على مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في المدينه
ومنعت بذلك نقل الاحتياطات والذخيره
واجبرت العدو على الانسحاب لخطوط دفاع
اخرى العمليات الهجوميه الناجحه لقواتنا
في سوليدار خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
اسفرت عن مقتل اكثر من 700 جندي اوكراني
وتدمير اكثر من 300 قطعه سلاح تابعه
للقوات الاوكرانيه
تقدر تعليقات مصدقهليه
حذيفه عادل ومن موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا الطعمه مرحبا بكم ابدا معك كاتيا
يبدو ان اوكرانيا ما زالت تسر على موقفها
الرافض لكل الانباء التي يعني تاتي من
سوليدار خاصه في ظل التصريحات الاخيره عن
سيطره كامله روسيه على المدينه ما الحقيقه
وكيف تنظر
الى هذه التصريحات من كيف
مرحبا خالد حقيقه يعني التصريحات السيطره
على هذه المدينه همم ليست هي اليوم الاول
التي تظهر بها هذه تصريحات كنا قد شاهدنا
خلال الايام السابقه ايضا من مجموعه التي
قالت انها قامت بالسيطره على مركز المدينه
بشكل كامل ااه وكان هناك غياب واضح
لتاكيدات الدفاع التي اكدت اليوم بدورها
بشكل رسمي السيطره الكاميرا همم على مدينه
سوليدار وكما تحدثت انها قامت بتحديد 700
مقاتله الاوكراني هناك وكان ذلك بفضل قوات
الانسان في شمال وجنوب مدينه سلدار وهذا
طبعا له اهميه كبيره كما قالت الدفاع
باهميه استراتيجيه لقطع الامدادات عن
القوات الاوكرانيه الموجوده الان في مدينه
باخ موت وهو الهدف التالي الذي سيكون لي
القوات الروسيه طبعا همم اعيد ان اؤكد
كمان ايضا على ان هناك ايضا كان تناقض بين
همم تصريحات وزاره الدفاع وقواتر التي
بدورها كانت اكدت انها هي القوات الوحيده
الموجوده في هذه المدينه اذا كما تحدثت
بشكل رسمي الدفاع بانها تمت همم او تمت
السيطره بشكل كامل على هذه المدينه من قبل
القوات الروسيه وان القوات الاوكرانيه
هربت من هذه المدينه وكان هناك نشر
الفيديوهات على وسائل الاعلام الروسيه
التي همم نشر فيها طبعا حديث للسكان همم
المحليين في هذه المدينه عن الاوضاع هناك
وعن الاعمال الختاليه هناك وعن الوضع
بالمدينه لذلك يمكن فقط
الاعتماد على التصريحات الرسميه لوزاره
الدفاع بالاضافه لما يتم نشره من قبل همم
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه عن السيطره على هذه
المدينه بالفعل خالد
حذيفه ماذا عن كيف كيف تتعامل الان مع
واقع هذه المدينه سوليدار بعد اعلان روسيا
سيطر الكامل عليه
في الحقيقه اوكرانيا اقررت بدخول القوات
الروسيه
الى مدينه سوليدار ولكنها تنفي السيطره
الكامله للقوات الروسيه على هذه المدينه
تقول ان القتال ما زال يجري في المدينه
الجيش الاوكراني في وضع الدفاعي في
المدينه كذلك اقررت بصعوبه الاوضاع صرح
اكثر من المسؤول ااه لكن قبل ان اتحدث عن
تصريحات المسؤولين يعني اقول لك ما شاهدته
قبل 10 دقائق فقط من هذا المباشر وهو
فيديو رساله مسجله لاحد الضباط الذي اصبح
مشهورا الان من سوليدار وهو يرسل رسائل
يوميه من هذه المدينه مصوره يعني قبل 10
دقائق نشر فيديو مصور يوضح وجود القوات
الاخرانيه داخل سوليدار وكذلك قام بتصوير
هاتفه وهناك يوجد المدينه ويوجد الزمن
ويوجد التاريخ ثم بعد ذلك مباشره وجه
الكاميرا الى كاميرا مراقبه من كاميرات
المراقبه التي يستعملها الجيش لمراقبه
القوه يعني هو قال هو وكان على كاميرا
المراقبه ايضا هنالك عدد من الجنود الروس
داخل المدينه وقال نحن في سوليدار وهذه
قوه من قوات الروسيه والان سوف يتلقون
ضربه هذا كان مجمل الرساله التي وجهها
الضابط الاوكراني من داخل مدينه سوليدار
اما عن التصريحات الرسميه فان ميلار وهي
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اقرد بصعوبه
الوضع في سوليدار وقالت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه في وضع الدفاعي كذلك شريف تاي
وهو الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات في الشرق
قبل حوالي نصف ساعه فقط ايضا ان نشر رساله
وقال ان القوات همم روسي الاتحاديه تتعمد
نشر هذه الرسائل وهي تعتبر من ادوات الحرب
ولكن القوات الاوكرانيه في مواقعها في
موقع دفاع كذلك تحدث وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني على اليوم صباحا في لقاء
التلفزيوني وتحدث عن الوضع وقال ان القوات
تريد ان ترسل رسائل لتقول ان لديها علو
كعب على الجيش الروسي نفسه انها حتى اقوى
من الجيش الروسي وان يعني رئيس شركه يريد
ان يسيطر على هذه المدينه ليحقق مكازم
اقتصاديه طبعا تعلمون ان هذه المدينه يوجد
بها اكبر منجم للملح في اوروبا بشكل عام
ولذلك ترغب كما قال فافنا في السيطره
عليها ولكنه يؤكد ان خسائر الجيش الروسي
هي 10 اضعاف خسائر الجيش الاوكراني او كما
قال ان الجيش الروسي يخسر في اليوم حوالي
600 الى 700 جندي بينما عسر هذا الرقم فقط
تخسره القوات الاوكرانيا اصل هذه التطورات
خاصه
على الداخل الروسي في موسكو يعني خاصه في
ظل ما يراه بعض المراقبين بانه قد يكون
يمثل اول انتصار مهم بعد سلسل من الخسائر
والهزائم التي بني بها الجيش الروسي في
همم في الفتره السابق
صحيح ما تقول خالد هذا الانتصار او التقدم
اذا اردنا ان نقول انه تقدم للقوات
الروسيه حتى لو ان هذه المدينه هي صغيره
ولكن له دلالات كبيره ان روس يتحولت ليس
فقط كخط دفاع عن الاراضي التي سيطرت عليها
وانما الان هي بدات بالهجوم من جديد
لاسيطر على اراضي جديده
لتحرير كما تقول كامل اراضي ادم باز وطبعا
هذا له كان ايجابيا على الشارع الروسي بعد
سلسله من التراجع والانسحابات التي
شاهدناها في العام السابق طبعا هذا العام
الجديد ومع بدايه الخطط التي وضعها القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه الروسيه همم ثلاثه
ايضا تغييرات في همم تركيبات المسؤولين
همم عن العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا منذ
ايام هي دليل على ان روسيا تريد الان همم
دوم بعد التقويم الدوم المحرز الان المحرز
في مدينه سوليدار همم للسيطره على كامل
اراضي دون باز وبالتالي السيطر على مدينه
باخمود كما قالت وفيما بعد على كراماتوست
وصله فيانس كما تقول القوات الروسيه خالد
العربيه
هجوم قريبا من بلا روسيا بسبب الطبيعه
الجغرافيه القاسيه من جهتها اوضاعت اوضحت
الخارجيه الروسيه ان المناورات العسكريه
التي تجريها مع بيلاروسيا لمنع خصوم
البلدين من التصعيد مداخليا في روسيا فقال
طالب مجلس الدومه بمصادره املاك واصول
المواطنين الرؤوس منتقدين الجيش والحربي
في اوكرانيا اعتبارا رئيس البرلماني
الروسي ان الاجراءات الحاليه المعمول بها
فيما يخص انتقاد الحرب في اوكرانيا متمثله
في الغرامات ليست صارمه بشكل الكافر
حلفه شمال الاطلسي النيتو اعلن نشره
طائرات استطلاع محموله جوا مزوده بنظام
الانذار والتحكم في رومانيا بدايه من
الثلاثاء المقبل لمراقبه نشاط العسكريه
الروسي ذكر بيان الحلف ان نظام اكسي الذي
تتميز به الطائرات والاستطلاع يمكن اكتشاف
الطائرات على بعد مئات الكيلومترات مما
يجعلها
قادره على الردع والدفاع مع استمرار الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا البيان المشدد على
عزمي حل فنيت وحمايه كل شبر من اراضي دول
الاعضاء والدفاع عنه
يدرس الاتحاد الاوروبيه عقوبات الجديده ضد
ايران تشمل ما يقرب من اربعين فردا ومؤسسا
وبحسب صحيفه
وثائق هناك 17 شخص يفكر الاتحاد الاوروبي
في فرد عقوبات عليهم
سابقين في الحرس الثوري الايراني
وعضو البرلمانيه وزيرا ومسؤولا رفيع
المستوى في هيئه الاذاعه الايرانيه اما
المؤسسات التي يفرض عليها عقوبات من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي وقد تم ذكره منظمه تنظيم
الاتصالات الراديويه الايرانيه التي تلعب
دورا في ترشيد الانترنت
لقد كشفت مصادر مطلعه في بروكسل العربيه
ان مندوب الدول الاعضاء بالاتحاد
الاوروبيه يبحثون امكانيه ادراج الحرس
الثوريه الايرانيه في قوائم الارهاب
الاوروبيه ضمن خيارات عده للضغط على
السلطات الايرانيه ردا على استمرارها في
قمع الاحتجاجات اضافه المصادر من المانيا
تقترحه منذ فتره ادراج الحرس الثوري ككل
في قائمه الارهاب الاوروبيه
هولندا وتشيك في هذا المقترح وقالت
المصادر لمراسل العربيه ان المندوبين
يبحثون ايضا حزمه رائعه من العقوبه ضد
ايران على ان تصدر في اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه يوم الاثنين الثالث والعشرين من
يناير
بروكسيل ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نور
الدين الفريدي نور مرحبا بك ما هي حدود
فرض هذه العقوبات على الافراد والمؤسسات
وعلى الحرس الثوري ككل
اهلا خلف المشاورات متواصره على مستوى
اللجان المتخصصه ويمكن القول ان فيما
يتعلق بالحزمه الرابعه تم اعدادها من
ناحيه الفنيه والتقنيه والقانونيه ايضا
وسيتواصل بحثها بحثها في لجان المتخصصه
اخرى الى ان تصل الى طاوله المندوبين
الدائمين في منتصف الاسبوع المقبل
وان يتم الاعداد لهذه الحزمه حتى تقدم الى
وزراء خارجيه بعد نحويه بعد اقل من
اسبوعين مثل ما تفضلت هذه الحزمه تشمل
سبعه عشر مسؤولا من الحاسب الثوري من
الحكومه الايرانيه من القضاء الايراني
وتشمل ايضا 20 كيانا وبين هذه الكيانات
اثني عشر كيانا تابعا للحرس الثوري
الايرانيه هذه الحزمه الرابعه ستكون اشد
من الحزمات الثلاثه السابقه في شهر اكتوبر
ونوفمبر ولكن جميعها يؤكد اتجاه الاتحاد
الاوروبي خطوه بعد خطوه نحو التصعيد
والضغط المتزايدي على السلطات الايرانيات
ردا على معانها في قمع شعبها فيما يتعلق
بالجانب الاخر المتعلق بالحرس الثوري
الايراني
كم مره تحدثت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
على وجوب واهميه ادراج الحرس الثوريه
الايرانيه الى مطلع هذا الاسبوع ويبدو ان
المانيا حسب معلومات العربيه هي الدوله
التي تقوده الجهود الدبلوماسيه مدعومه منه
لندن
وجمهوريه التشيك في اتجاه ادراجي حزب عفوا
الحرس الثوري الايراني في قائمه الارهاب
الاوروبيه فرنسا تركت الباب مفتوحا في
مقطع الاسبوع عندما تحدث عن البحث مع
الشركاء في حزمه حزمه عقوبه جديده من دون
استبعاد اي شيء او اي خيار من ناحيه
المبدايه بما يعني ان الدبلوماسيه هناك
نوع من الانفتاح من جانب فرنسا لبحث هذا
الخيار ولكن في الساعات التي نتحدث عنها
هذا الامر لا يزال مجرد اقتراح لم يطرح
على اللجان المتخصصه
وانما هو مجرد اقتراح سيعرض على
الدبلوماسيين فردا ان هذه الاختراع عرض
فعلا يوم الاربعاء المقبل او في غزون
الايام فان هذا الامر سيتطلب وقت سيعود
الى اللجان المتخصصه الى اللجان القانونيه
قبل ان قبل ان يتم اتخاذ القرار السياسي
ويعرض لاحقا بمعنى انه الاقرب حسب معلومات
العربيه ان في غضون الاسبوعين يعني من هنا
الى 23 ستستر الحزمه الحزمه الرابعه من
العقوبات بينما موضوع الحرس الثوري
الايراني مطروح على الصعيد الدبلوماسي لكن
لا نعلمه الان كيف ستثير النقاشات لان
هناك مثل ما تعلم خالد بعض الاعتراضات
الاخرى التي تقول ان هذا الموضوع هو
الموضوع سياسي صرف همم معنى ان اتخاذ درجه
الحرس الثوري في قوائم الارهاب هي خطوه
سياسيه كبيره قد تعني ايضا ربما قطعه
قنوات الحوار
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يريد قطع قناه الحوار
القائمه بين جوزيف بريل وامير عبد العليان
على خلفيات سواء كان منها ما يتعلق
بالبرنامج النووي الايراني وقضايا اخرى
ذات سلسله بالوضع الاقليم جزيلا لك من
بروكسيل مراسله العربيه
بعد قليل
العربيه تلتقي عددا من متعه في ادمان
الشبوه في السعوديه وتعرضوا تجربه فتره
ادمانهم
اهلا بكم من جديد
اكثر من 25 الف طالب والطالب هي نتائج
اعلان لترشيد مبادره المسرح المدرسيه التي
تاتي بشراكه بين وزاره التعليم السعوديه
وهيئه المسرح والفنون الادائيه وبالتعاون
مع جماعه مناش
مبادره المسرح المدرسي تستهدف ايضا تغطيه
ما يزيد عام 19000 مدرسه حكوميه في
السعوديه يكرمون من خلالها افضل الف
مسرحيه على خمس مراحل الزمنيه تصل الى 27
شهرا على ان تتناسق المخرجات مع احتياجات
السوق الثقافي في البلاد
وده كده رئيس التنفيذي لهيئه المسرح
والفنون الادائيه سلطان البازعي ان تدشين
برنامج المسرح المدرسي بشراكه مع وزاره
التعليم يعد حدثا تاريخيا وذلك نظيره
شموليه من خلال استهدافكافه المدارس في
السعوديه لفئتين البنين والبنات والنتائج
الاولويه الجديده له
اول مره ينفذ برنامج بهذه الشموليه بحيث
يستهدف جميع مدارس التعليم العام للبنين
والبنات ايجاد مشرف نشاط مسرحي في كل
مدرسه او مشرفه
وتحقيق هذا الحراك
لتطوير وتعميق نشاط المسرح المدرسي عن
طلاب وطالباتنا وهذا الهدف الرئيسي اللي
نشترك في في في هيئه المسرح والمنظمه
الثقافيه مع وزاره التعليم
وحققنا الحقيقه نوع من التعاون
مثمر جدا همم اثمر انه فعلا بدا البرنامج
يعني قبل حتى الاحتفال بتدشينه والاعلام
عنه البرنامج بدا وكاله النتائج الاوليه
مباشره جدا
وبتصور ان شاء الله انه سيواصل النجاح حتى
تحقيق في الوقت المستهدف
[موسيقى]
انظمه التطوير المسرح المدرسي في وزاره
التربيه والتعليم سابقا علي السيد علي
حياك الله مرحبا استاذ سلطان
همم الحقيقه فعلا هي حدث تاريخي همم اسمح
لي انا نهني وزاره الثقافه واهني وزاره
التعليم على هذه المبادره التاريخيه اللي
تمثل عمل مشترك ايضا لبناء همم
طالب السعودي من القاعده من المسرح همم
التعليم العام بالمرحله الابتدائيه
والمتوسطه والثانويه انا اعتقد فعلا انها
مرحله تاريخيه وهي ايضا تتويج لجهود يعني
نخبه كبيره من المسرحيين الذين عملوا في
المسرح المدرسي على طوال عده يعني ليش شو
شهر
حوالي 25,000 معلم ومعلمات 19,000 مدرسه
هناك ايضا همم حساب همم للفائض او للفاقد
يعني العدد كم المستهدف يغطي كامل مدارس
المملكه في السابق كانت الجرعات التدريبيه
التي تقدم في وزاره التعليم او وزاره
المعارف سابقا متقطعه همم تخضع للاجتهادات
الشخصيه سواء في اداره النشاط والوزاره او
في ادارات التعليم همم
فاضل همم المعلم همم المدرب مسرحيه في
المدارس كان هو من ابرز معوقات العمل في
المسرح المدرسي الان هذه المبادره تاتي
شامله
بالاستعانه مع شريك عالمي وهمم يعني صاحب
خبره في مجال المسرح المدرسي اعتقد ان شاء
الله هناك تكون يعني حدث تاريخي ننتظر
نتائج ان شاء الله في المستقبل بعد عامين
حينما ينزل هؤلاء المعلمون والمعلمات الى
الميدان التربوي وهم مدربون ليقدموا او
يحققوا اهداف المسرح المدرسي كمان هل هناك
حوافز تقدمها الوزاره المعلم يعني الدخول
في هذا البرنامج والاستفاده
يعني احنا نتمنى ان تكون هناك حوافز هناك
طبعا
كان هناك رائد نشاط له حوافز انه يكون له
تخفي الحصه الدراسيه
كله فرصه في التدريب والتاهيل همم ايضا
كان في هناك حوافز معينه مثلا همم لبعض
المتميزين ان يكون همم تاخير همم عودته في
الاجازه يعني زياده الاجازه عن غيره انا
اعتقد من الحوافز المهمه التي ممكن ان
تقدم للمعلم المدرب في المسرح المدرسي مثل
هذا تخفيض النصاب الدراسي ايضا ممكن ان
يكون من المحفزات همم تاخير العوده همم
بدايه العام الدراسي همم ايضا ممكن ايضا
همم اتاحه الفرصه للتاهيل والتطوير ايضا
لمستويات اعلى همم همم ايمن ممكن
الاستفاده من الحصه طبعا هذه
المبادره حسب ما فهمنا امس او قبل امس في
المؤتمر الصحفي انها تستهدف النشاطات
اللاصفيه انا اعتقد انه في المرحله ما بعد
هذه المبادره ان يكون لوزاره ااا تعليم
مراجعه
لاضافه هذا المجال في المرحله في داخل حجه
كيف راح يكون واقع الميسر المسرح المدرسي
الان بعدها هذه المبادره من حيث مثلا نقول
المواضيع المطروحه في من حيث ال- ال-
النتائج اللي ممكن ايضا على احد المستوى
الممثلين على مستوى الكذلك المدربين
وغيرها انت ليش تتوقع هو في الحقيقه طبعا
المسرح المدرسي خلينا نقول انه يصير بخطين
متوازيين الخط المهاري والخط القيمي
المسرح المدرسي يقوم على مهارات تنميه
مهارات وقد استاذ الطالب وايضا حتى المعلم
مهارات الالقاء مهارات مواجهه الجمهور
مهاره الاداره اداره العمل مهاره الضيافه
والاستقبال من خلال حفل المدرسي
ومجمل يعني عده مهارات كثيره ايضا الجانب
القيامي ما يقدم المسرح المدرسي من قيم
قيم اا وطنيه قيام اخلاقيه قيم همم
تربويه تعامل التسامح همم يعني هذا الجانب
اعتقد انه سينعكس لان المعلم المدرب
يستطيع ان يتعامل مع المسرح المدرسي وفق
احتياجات المرحله يعني نعرف احنا عندنا
مرحله صفوف اوليه مرحله مرحله متقدمه من
مرحله ابتدائيه ومرحبا متوسطه ثانويه كل
مرحله من المراحل لها احتياجاتها التربويه
والنفسيه المعلم المسرح المدرب يستطيع ان
يتعامل لا يمكن اني مثلا اقدم مسرحيه
تناسب طلاب الصف المرحله الثانويه وهو
يقدمها في الصف للطلاب المرحله الابتدائيه
او المرحله الاوليه كلها مرحله لاخصوصيه
واحتياجات ايضا هناك ما يخص
[موسيقى]
له دور ايضا في [__]
راتيجي هذا من خلال الالعاب التربويه من
خلال القصص الحركيه من خلال تمثيل الدور
اثناء شرح
الحصه الدراسيه او المقرر الدراسي هذه
جوانب مهمه جدا يجب ان نغفر في المحيط
المدرسي والحوافذ اللي يمكن ان تقدم حتى
للطلاب حتى يعني
المشاركه في المهرجانات يعني من فوائد
المسرح المدرسي حين وهو المسابقات التي
تنظمها الوزاره تنظم الوزاره المسابقه
سنويه في كل عام في منطقه او في اداره
تعليميه هذه فرصه وحوادث للمتميزين انه
يتعرفون على وطنهم يعني لما انا طالب وانا
في المرحله الابتدائيه والمرحله المتوسطه
اذهب من الرياض برحله الى ابها او الى
نجران او الى عرعر فانا اتعرف على جانب
همم من جوان عفوا منطقه من بلاد العزيزه
همم اكتسب معرفه اكتسب صداقات فهذه جوانب
همم خارج الصندوق المسرح المدرسي يعني
ولكنها تصب في همم المخرجات التي همم
يقدمها المسرح المدرسه يعطيكم العافيه
شكرا جزيلا لك على التواجدك معنا علي سعيد
عدو لجنه تطوير المسرح المدرسي في وزاره
التربيه والتعليم شكرا لك شكرا لكم
اطلق مركز الملك عبد العزيز الثقافي
العالمي اكبر الماثون نوعي للقراءه على
مستوى ثلاث مدن سعوديه هي الظهران الرياض
وتبوك الماراثون الذي يستمر ثلاثه ايام
يهدفوا للتحفيز المجتمع على القراءه ويدعم
مبادره السعوديه الخضراء وياتي ضمن برنامج
اثراء القراءه في دولته الثامنه سيتكتل
مركز اثراء بزراعه همم شجره مقابل
انضم الينا من مركز اثراء بالظهران مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي حياك الله عبد
الرحمن عبد الرحمن وايش التفاصيل هذه
المبادره المركز
اثراء هذا المركز الذي يضم اساسا مكتبه
ضخمه للغايه تصل مساحتها الى 6000 متر
مربع واكثر من اربعه طوابق نحن حدثتكم من
هذه المكتبه مكتبه اثراء الذي ايضا تضم
بعض الفعاليات المتعلقه بمراتون القراءه
وانه هناك شاشات لاستعراض عدد الصفحات
التي وصل اليها الماراثون حتى الان سادع
زميلي همم النصر ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات في
هذه المكتبه قبل نتحدث عن مبادره خالد
يعني تتحدث عن هذه المكتبه المميزه للغايه
تضم 10,000 همم تقريبا رف وهناك ايضا اكثر
من 300,000 كتاب مطبوع في هذه المكتبه
بالاضافه الى عشره الاف كتاب رقمي وايضا
خالد كتاب صوتي 60% من الكتب الموجوده في
هذه المكتبه ضخمه للغايه هي باللغه باللغه
العربيه واربعون في المئه باللغه
الانجليزيه ايضا اثراء فيها تقريبا 51
عمود في هذه المكتبه كل عمود [__] مطلع
لاهم القصائد العربيه على مر التاريخ ايضا
نشاهد هنا على الشاشات بعض المعلومات عن
ماراثون القراءه المتعلق بهذه المبادره
هذه المبادره خالد يعني سيحصل الفائزون
فيها على ميداليات قسمت الاربعه فئات
ميداليا نحاسيه همم سياخذها الذي قرا 100
صفحه ومن ميداليه برونزيه من قرا 200 صفحه
ميداليه فضيه من قرا 500 صفحه واخيرا
ميداليه ذهبيه لمن قرا الف همم صفحه طبعا
هذه مبادره في ثلاث مدن هي الرياض
والمنطقه الشرقيه وتبوك
ومتوقع خلال الفتره المقبله يكون هناك
مبادرات عديده واكثر في اكثر من منطقه
بهدف تحفيز الشباب السعودي وجميع فئات
المجتمع على القراءه طبعا هم بداوا قام
قليله يعني 100 صفحه يعتبر رقم جيد في
البدايه لكن يطمحون في المستقبل الى قراءه
المزيد من الصفحات كما نشاهد هنا على
السقف همم مجموعه الصفحات المقروءه حتى
الان خالد في الاعلى لعلى الكاميرا تظهرها
حتى الان وصلوا الى 100 وايه واثنين و97
صفحات وعدد الاشجار المزروعه الى الان
1029 شجره هذا البيان او ال- الارقام
تتغير مع مرور الوقت كلما اا تم قراءه صحف
او صفحات اكثر يتم تعديل الارقام اكثر
فاكثر ايضا هذه تعتبر ملاذ جيد للاطفال
والطلاب القراءه الان يعني ربما يقرا كتاب
قصص
مواقع خاصه
طبعا في متابعه من قبل مركز اثراء للطلاب
الطلاب مسجله اسماءهم يتم متابعتهم اول
باول في الثلاث مناطق الرياض والشرقيه
وتبوك ويتم ايضا متابعتهم اول في اول
فعندما ينتهي من القراءه يقول لهم انتهيت
من القراءه ثم يتم تسجيل الارقام اولا
باول هناك مندوبين من مركز اثراء بالتعاون
ايضا مع المكتبات العامه في المناطق
لمتابعه هذه البرامج اولا ابي اول خالد
هذا المكان خالد ايضا هناك لمن اراد ان
يقوم بالمذاكره لديه اختبارات يريد ان
يقرا هناك عضويه في هذه
الكتابه
الشخصيه
الارقام انه انا مثلا قرات 100 صفحه على
سبيل المثال يعني ممكن انا قلت ان جاري
يكون دقيق للغايه يعني خاصه ان الذين
سجلوا به المبادره غالبا يكونوا من
المهتمين بالقراءه والجدين في هذا الموسم
الجوائز ليست الجوائز نقيه خالديه جوازات
نعم جوائز معنويه وميداليه فبالتالي لنكن
هناك تلاعب في ما يتعلق بالارقام بل هناك
يعني جديه وصرامه في ما يتعلق بهذه
المبادره شكرا
من مركز اثراء في الظاهره
لحظه تطهيه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك في
السعوديه محاوله تهريب اكثر من 81 كيلو
جرام من ماده الحشيش المخدره بعد العثور
عليها مخبا في احدى المركبات القادمه الى
المملكه عبر منفذ الوديعه في المنطقه
الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
كشفت اللجنه الوطنيه لمكافحه المخدرات في
السعوديه من تحضيراتها او كثافه من
تحضيراتها من استخدام ماده الشب والمخدره
التي تتسبب في تعزيز السلوك العدواني
واعراض الهلوسه للمتعطي العربيه زياره احد
المراكز العلاجيه للمدمنين الشباب في
السعوديه
تلك الماده المخدرات
قتل والده ووالدته واخته واخيه حرقا بعد
محاصرتهم في المنزل اضافه الى حاله عنف
اخرى صادبه كلها شواهد على ما يرتكبه
متعاطي الشباب من جرائم
ولمعرفه واقع متعاطينا لهذه الماده
المهلكه قمنا بزياره بعضهم في رحلتهم من
العلاجيه
استقبلنا عبد الله في غرفته له تاريخ طويل
في التعاطي الذي قاده في الاخير لتعاطي
الشهوه جرعات بسيطه فقط كانت كفيله بقيامه
باعمال عدوانيه
وادراكه وحتى ذكرته
طلعت من البيت
قلت انا وينش اللي صاير ايش الموضوع
يا رجل انت
ماشي ورايح للحاره الاسلاميه
منهم هم من مدمنين الشباب وهي نسبه ارتفعت
بشكل كبير جدا خلال السنه الماضيه
احمد هو الاخر بدا رحله ادمانه في سن
الرابعه عشر
يتعافى من الشاب منذ سبعه اشهر تعرف على
الشاب من احدى المسلسلات الامريكيه وتعطه
قبل ثلاث سنوات رغبه في نشوه اعلى الا ان
الشك اصبح عنوان حياته
وقت النوم
بدي اسمع صوتك عندي في الغرفه اسمع ناس
تسولف تضحك وانا كنت مطنش كنت جالس على
الجوال يمين يسار
ما عندي احد
ومنها الهلال جدتي
هو مو حقيقي
اكثر من اربع حالات في الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
صغيره جرائم الشبوه هزت حتى مجتمعات
المدمنين انفسهم كثيرون لا يزالون في قاع
الادمان واخرون يبحثون عن من ياخذ بايديهم
لايمالهم بانهم مجرمون وان حدوث الماسات
مساله وقت
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض
احد اشد المواد المخدره خطوره من المخدرات
المحظوره عالميا
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقول ان خمسه في
المئه من متعاطي المخدرات محظوره تتراوح
اعمارهم بين 15 عاما و 64 عاما منظمه
الصحه العالميه تقول ايضا بان 15% من
متعاطي المخدرات المحظوره يصلون الى مرحله
الادمان وزاره الصحه السعوديه تقول بان
الشبو ماده تؤدي بمتعاطيها الى الانتحار
ومن اعراض تعاض الشبو جنون الارتياب فقدان
الوزن القلق والعدوانيه من اضرار طاعات
الشعوب زياده معدل ضربات القلب ارتفاع
درجه الحراره السكته الدماغيه
انضم الينا في فيديوهاتنا من الرياض
استشاري الطب النفسي والادمان الدكتور
احمد الشهري دكتور احمد حياك الله يا خالد
دكتور خليني ابدا معك اول شيء من
سالفه او مساله زياده عدد وكثافه
التحذيرات اللي شفناها خلال الفتره
الماضيه من ماده الشيب والمخدر
السبب هل هو لزياده اعداد المتعاطيين ولا
العلاقه
التعاطي بجرائم سجلت ربما في الفتره
الاخيره انا اعتقد من وجهه نظري انه بسبب
ال ااه ارتباط ماده الشبه بالجرائم وخصوصا
الجرائم ذات الطابع الانيف همم يكون فيه
همم طالع صادم حتى همم المجتمع همم بشكل
عام همم يعني الجرائم قد تكون يعني مصنفه
تصنيفات معينه ولكن في جرائم معينه مرتبطه
تكون ذات طابع همم نساوي والاعلام بشكل
هذه الجرائم تتناول بشكل كبير في وسائل
الاعلام لذلك تكون مولفه الانتماء
جدته
همم
في المركز همم الان من خلال هل لديكم او
احصائيات باعداد المتعاطيين خلينا يجيكم
المتعاطيين بشكل يومي ولا بشكل اسبوعي هلا
لمستهم اي فرق بين متعاطي هذه الماده في
الفتره الاخيره مقارنه
ما في شك انه الفتره الماضيه همم يعني
تقريبا خلال ثلاث سنوات الماضيه في همم
بدايه ظهور حالات همم تعاطي الشباب وصابقا
همم لم تكن موجود يكون في تعاطي مواد اخرى
مثلا حشيش الكبتاجون همم
المنبهات بعض الافيونات ولكن الفتره
الاخيره بدات تظهر حالات تعاطي الشباب همم
طبعا لعده عوامل همم من فتره لاخرى غالبا
يكون ايضا تعاطي الشبو مصاحب يتعاطي مواد
مواد اخرى همم يعني
من الغاء من النادر انه يكون بدايه
التعاطي
من ناحيه يعني خبره سريريه وكلينكيه غالبا
يكون في تعاطي السابق لمواد اخرى ثم بعد
ذلك تطور الوضع اللي عوامل اخرى لمحاول
التجربه موضوع الشبوه واحنا نعرف ان الشبو
بشكل عام شده او سرعه التعلق او خواصها
ادمانيه عاليه مقارنه ببعض
همم ما نقول من اول جرعه ولكن في تصنيف
المواد المخدره بشكل عام في قوه همم قوه
او خلينا نقول ميزات ادمانيا للمعده لها
خصائص ادمانيه او سرعه التعلق الشباب من
اسرع المواد اللي ممكن الشخص يتعلق او
يدمن عليها مقارنه ببعض همم المواد
المخدره الاخرى ليس بالضروره من اول مره
ولكن بسرعه او بشكل اسرع من بقيه المواد
الاخرى لذلك همم تجد حتى التركيز بشكل عام
في بعض المرات في وسائل الاعلام لانه سرعه
التداهور او سرعه همم الادمان بشكل عام
مقارنه بالمواد الاخرى هو اسرع لذلك اثره
اسرع
شو اللي يحصل لي متعاطي
الشادو ما هي الفئه الاكثر ربما مشاهده
همم الفئه الحاليه غالبا يكونون المراهقين
وصغار السن يعني مرحله همم
ممكن نستطيع ان نقول من ال 14 الين همم ال
25 بشكل عام فغالبا هذه المرحله همم هم
اكثر من يكونون يعني همم
متعاطيين لماده الشبو او اكثر من همم
المراحل العمريه همم الاخرى هذه من 14 25
في فرق بين
المتعاقين من الذكور والاناث طبعا همم ما
نقدر نقول انه في فرق لانه لا توجد لان
يعني دراسه واضحه وحتى لكن اكثر الحالات
اللي تجيء يكون اغلى بذور ولكن لا يعني
انهم اكثر ولكن همم قابليه ذكور وضغط
الاهالي بشكل عام لطلب العلاج اكثر مع
الذكور اكثر من البنات او همم النساء بشكل
عام متعاطي
الانوهل بالفعل انه هو الاخطر هو الاعنى
فعلى عقول همم المدمنين هو الاقرب ارتكاب
اي جريمه نعم مثل ما ذكرت لك خالد انه
الشبو الشبو الشبو ااا يعني مثل ذكرتك
خصائص الكيميائيه
وقدرته على افراز المواد الكيميائيه بشكل
قوي وبشكل كبير
يعجل من سرعه الادمان ايضا تاثيره على
الخلايا الدماغيه والتاثيرات السلوكيه
والنفسيه اعلى واسرع من باقي المواد
الاخرى لذلك نجد انه همم وجود الاعراض
السلوكيه العنيفه موضوع الاعراض الدهنيه
موضوع الاعراض الشقوق الهلاوس ومن ثم بعد
ذلك يتم ارتكاب الجرائم بناء على هذه
المؤثرات او هذه التاثيرات همم المتعلقه
بماده الشابو
خليني انتم لو تذكر لي قصه وردت لكم يمكن
خلال فتره الماضيه هل تذكر قصه معينه
مؤثره للدكتوره
القصص بشكل عام كثيره
وغالبا يعني انا خلال عملي يعني ولله
الحمد يعني ما وصلني حاله مثلا جرائم قتل
ولكن اعتداء اعتداء على الامهات اعتداء
على الاباء موجود
بخصوصا يكون تحت تاثير الشبه في بعض
الاحيان حتى ممكن الاهالي همم ما يكون
عندهم علم او همم
اشتباه بحاله الادمان الا لما يصل لحاله
ارتكاب جريمه او بعد ياخذ وقت حتى يصل
للمرحله هذه الدكتوره ليس بالضروره هو
يعتمد لكل شخص له عوامل معينه مثل ما
ذكرتك كميه الاستخدام
وفتره الاستخدام لها لها علاقه
همم علاج متوفر وليس مستح همم ياخذ وقت
ياخذ وقته يعني هي رحله احنا دائما ومن
هذا المنبر نبين انه رحله همم علاج
الادمان بشكل عام هي رحله وليست يعني
مرحله واحده فقط هي رحله تبدا بتدرج وبعده
مراحل معينه وفيها همم مجاهده والتزام من
المريض ومن عائله همم المريض انا اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا على هذه الافاده والمعلومات
الدكتور احمد الشهري استشاري الطب النفسي
شكرا لك شكرا لك
الرابعه ايضا بعد قليل
معرض مجاني
الرابعه تتجول داخله
اهلا بكم في لقاء خاص مع العربيه كد نائب
رئيس لقطار الحرمين والمشاعر المقدسه
المهندس ريان الحربي
مشاركه قائدات قطارات سعوديات في نقل الحج
هذا العام الطاقه الاستيعابيه لقطار
الحرمين تكفي لنقل اكثر من اثنين وسبعين
الفحل
هذا العام باذن الله كما تم تصريح يوم امس
سيتم تشغيل قطار المشاعر بالطاقه القصوى
الكامله كما كان قبل الجائحه نستهدف باذنه
تشغيل كافه القطارات وعددها 17 القطار
الواحد الذي قدرت نقل 3 راكب في الرحله
والدينا قدره نقل تعدديه ستصل الى 72,000
راكب في الساعه لنقل الحجاج بين كافه
المحطات المشاعر المقدسه بدايه من واحد
يناير تم اعتماد اول دفعه قاعدات قطارات
في قطاع الحماسيه فباذن الله هذا العام
سيشاركنا اخوات قاده القطار في نقل
المعتمرين والحجاج في كافه بين كافه
المحطات باذن الله
تعد منطقه
تحتظرها العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ضمن
فعاليات الموسم احدا اكبر مناطق فعاليات
العروض المشوقه تضم الفعليه التي انطلقت
امس عدد من العروض الحيه بتجارب اربع
مستوحه من الافلام العالميه اضافه الى
معارض ومجسمات تحمل افلام الشهيره
اسامه القاسم مصر
اهلا وسهلا تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع مشاهدين
قناه العربيه بالتاكد اليوم وقف في هذه
المنطقه منطقه مجنيشن بارك هنا في موسم
الرياض التي تم افتتاحها بالامس طبعا هذه
المنطقه تضم عددا من المعارض معارض
السيارات الكبرى هو يعتبر اكبر معرض
السيارات في الشرق الاوسط في عدد من
السيارات الكلاسيكيه وعدد ايضا من
السيارات الرياضيه اترككم الان في جوله
حول هذه المنطقه التي سنتحدث عنها بشكل
اوسع طبعا هذه المنطقه تضم عدد كبير جدا
من السيارات الكلاسيكيه والرياضيه ايضا
هناك فرصه للتعديل عليها ولك ايضا في
الجهه الاخرى منطقه الافلام والمسلسلات
والتجارب الشيئه جدا الكثير من الاثاره
والفن تجتمع في هذه المنطقه التي تضم ايضا
عددا من المقاهي والمطاعم العالميه جاءت
هذه المنطقه لتعزيز اهميه المسلسلات
والصوره الوثائقيه الحيه التي يحب ان
يشاهدها ويستمتع بها الزوار السائحين نشهد
ايضا الان
فدوه وجود عدد كبير جدا من الزوار
والسائحين لهذه المنطقه الاعداد كبيره جدا
وايضا بالتاكيد هم مستمتعون بهذه الرحله
يعني احنا اتكلم خالد اليوم عن منطقه
بالتاكيد انها همم مثاليه للكثير من محبين
المسلسلات والافلام العالميه يعني على
سبيل المثال همم مسلسل لاكاسا دي بابل
البروفيسور الاسباني وايضا سكوت جيم عدد
ايضا كبير جدا من المعارض التي تحمل هذا
النوع والطبع الكبير جدا لمحبين الافلام
والمسلسلات الوثائقيه هذه المنطقه ايضا
تضم عددا ايضا من الافلام والمسلسلات التي
يعيش تجربتها الزائر والسائح هنا يعني هو
يدخل المنطقه التي تحمل هذا الاسم اسم
المسلسل او اسم همم الفيلم مثلا يدخل لهذه
المرحله يدخل لهذه المنطقه يعيش التجربه
بالكامل كما كان يشاهدها عبرات
خالد التشهد توافق كبير جدا من الزوار
السائحين
انا بصراحه خاطري اعيش لكاس الذباب لاني
احب المسلسل اللي بشكل كبير جدا لكن احنا
جايين اليوم بالتاكيد عشان نعيش هذه
التجربه بشكل اوسع وايضا نعيش كل التجارب
الموجوده هنا هذه التجارب بشكل كبير جدا
هي رائعه لانه بكل امانه لما انفتحت
المنطقه العام الماضي في موسم الماضي كان
هناك توافق كبير جدا من الزوار والسائحين
لانه في كثير متابعين ومشاهدين لهذه
المسلسلات والافلام سواء الوثائقيه او حتى
الاكشن في اليوم هنا لما تجيء في منطقه
واحده وفي موسم الرياض هذا يعطي انطباع
جيد عن انه في كثير متابعين ومستمتعين جدا
بهذه التجارب السيارات ايضا محبين السياره
معك فرصه وجودهم اليوم في هذه المتحركه
طيب اترك ايضا همم ممكن ناخذ الان اكثر من
جوله ماجد في هذه المنطقه الزميل ماجد
الاهدل ياخذنا الان ايضا في جوله هذه
المنطقه تشهد كما نشاهد الان ااه توافق
كبير جدا من الزوار والسائحين في منطقه
السيارات الرياضيه الموجوده هناك هنا ايضا
في الزاويه الاخرى السيارات الكلاسيكيه
القديمه عدد كبير جدا من الشركات اتت هنا
تعرض هذه
الكبيره جدا تقريبا ابرز الشركات التي
تنتج وتصدر السيارات العالميه الكلاسيكيه
ايضا والرياضيه متواجده في هذه المنطقه
هناك ايضا عدد من المسلسلات الافلام
الوثائقيه العروض الموسيقيه التي تاتي في
اطار تعزيز هذه الهويه البصريه لموضوع
المسلسلات والافلام الوثائقيه انا بصراحه
هنحاول ان احنا نعيش التجربه بشكل اوسع
يلا خليك تستمتع بتجربه شكرا لك من
فعاليات منطقه معرض الرياض ام ماجد
العربيه لو سمحت
اعلن مركز الارصاد السعوديه توقعاته لطقس
اليوم التي تضمته طول امطار تتراوح بين
المستوى المتوسط في عدد من المناطق حول
السعوديه
الارصاد السعوديه اوضحت ايضا ان احتماليه
جريان السيول تتزايده مع احتماليه طول
الامطار مصحوبه بتساقطات من البرد
الى العناوين
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن سيطرتها على مدينه
وتصف المعارك في المدينه بالعنيفه
الاتحاد الاوروبيه على افراد وكيانه
ايرانيه وادراج الحرس الثوري على قوائم
الارهاب
الجمارك السعوديه تحبطوا تهريب اكثر من 80
كلغ من الحشيش عبر منفذ الوديعه
تشيله مبادره جديده لدعم المسرح المدرسي
في اكثر من 19.000 ما الدراسه في السعوديه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]